women are losing out on tens of
thousands of pounds of employer pension
contributions because of the gender pay
gap that's according to research
published today found out that last year
men under the age of 35 received 217
pounds more in pension contributions
than women of the same age and over the
last four years employer contributions
amounted to three thousand four hundred
and ninety five pounds for men but only
two thousand four hundred and eighty
nine pounds for women that could result
in a shortfall a forty seven thousand
pounds for female employees by the time
they retire new partnerships at Zurich
insurance it commissioned a survey which
looked at more than a quarter of a
million pension plans so Rose how do you
arrive at those figures what was the
methodology yeah so it was a significant
piece of research that we did and as you
said we looked quarter of a million
pension plans over a four year period so
between 2013 and 2016 and as you said
our findings were women will have forty
seven thousand pounds less in their
pension parts based on employer
contributions compared to their male
counterparts there are quite a
significant figure I mean the quite
scary thing about this is that you're
not taking into account investment
returns this is purely employer
contributions that's absolutely correct
there's no no consideration for
investment returns at all so we've just
looked at average earnings index we've
looked at we've taken that figure of 217
pounds used it for an individual a woman
age 21 rolled that through her work in
career and assumes a retirement age of
63 so with no other factors taken into
consideration its 47,000 pounds
now I said in the introduction that it's
down to the gender gap but I mean are
there other factors as well I mean
potentially you know women having career
breaks to have babies for example well
what's the biggest single contributor to
this factor to this short form that's
right in there a number of contributors
and we've highlighted three the first of
which is the the gender pay gap so you
know men what men earn 18% more than
women in fact so as a result of making
contributions into the pension fell in a
pounds and pence perspective they'll
have more going in than a woman will
have you alluded to women taking career
break so when they're out of the way
place because they might be looking
after a family for that period of time
they're not actually making pension
contributions equally they're not
capturing employee employer pension
contributions as well and but when they
go back to the workplace that all
resumes again but they may not go back
to the workplace or equally they may
choose to work flexibly right yeah I
mean could this improve over time I mean
there is a lot of everywhere there's
there's some evidence that the gender
pay gap is starting to decline I mean is
this a problem that will rectify itself
over time do you feel there is evidence
that the gap is starting to close I
think a recent piece of research a
couple of weeks ago said that it was for
certainly for under 30s but that's
around men taking and the research
showed that men were taking lower paid
jobs or part-time work so it's not that
women are getting paid more it's that
men that are choosing to take ballet so
so that's that piece of research more
importantly there is a gap and we can't
wait for that gap to close action needs
to be taken and what the research has
shown is that there are a number of
areas where we can take some action but
it's clearly identified that there are
gaps so what so what do you think should
happen then what are the what are these
actions that need taking sure so first
of all we think there's a big piece of
work to do around financial education
and for women specifically so they can
go to their employees and understand
what what's available to them for their
pension schemes how much can they
contribute what be matched by their
employer and if they pay more how much
more they will match so that's really
really important to understand that
equally women can use their financial
advisors or their existing insurance
companies and pension providers to use
their tools to find out how they want
their retirement to look and to model
and project for that but on the other
side there's a piece of work to do
around lobbying government so from a
workplace perspective and
auto-enrollment there's a threshold of
10,000 pounds where women were were
individuals don't automatically fall
into the pension scheme